s'il vous plaît est ce que vous pouvez
nous donner des conseils pour éviter la
gueule de bois au lendemain de réveillon
j'avais produit de manger la soupe à
l'oignon marzolo sûrement noria manche
et puis rester au lit je suppose ah ben
faut boire un bon boulot à des agents
est ce que bon quand on a une bonne
crise de foi c'est un jus de citron
avant avant la crise de foi ou s'il ya
un réveillon j'attendais de voir une
cuillère d'huile et puis je sais plus
j'ai pas vraiment fait attention
un blanc d'oeuf peut-être on on dit
aussi gober à 9 mai et autres je sais
plus ce que vous avez un truc contre la
gueule de bois au lendemain du nouvel an
oui je bois des nouveaux encore oui je
prenais en combien de jours jusqu'à ce
que ça disparaisse ou d'oubli ok général
ça marche pas toutes façons ok qu'est ce
que vous faites ce nouvel an
rien je bois mais quand j'ai une [ __ ] en
général je prends la casse et zaire
enfin les trucs comme ça quand les
conneries habituelles mais sinon à fait
comme moi à vichy badoit et cetera et
cetera
il faut boire le lendemain matin une
bonne came ami avec un citron pressé
dedans c'est efficace
enfin j'ai pas avant avant de boire je
sais pas vous gobez à neuf alors vous
avez une cuillère d'huile faudra prendre
de l'aspect gic avec un ou un verre de
lait avec un jaune d'oeuf battu le nord
évitez de trop boire je pense surtout ça
mais je pense que nouvelle enseigne
jours de fête alors on peut se permettre
ça une fois par an comme avait pas de
trucs de grand-mère de grand mère
non disons que si on se prendre une
cuite l'avait auchan panneaux quoique ce
soit il faut se réveiller avec un verre
de champagne
je pense que ce meilleur je bois perrier
perrier menthe
vers quelle heure à peu près vers 3
heures du matin j'avais entendu parler
d'un remède d'une bonne dizaine de
persil est-ce que vous pouvez nous
donner des conseils pour éviter la
gueule de bois le lendemain du réveillon
c'est pas beau c'est le seul whissell
sérieux il ya vraiment pas moyen de
faire autrement au moyen pas moyen
notamment d'accords
qu'est ce qui vous fait le soir du
nouvel an va me coucher je vais vous
demander un petit conseil qui pourrait
servir à savoir sophie monsieur s'il
vous plaît bonjour est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner des conseils pour
éviter la gueule de bois le lendemain
des réveillons pour pouvoir voir que du
contrat que toute la nuit de l'eau du
robinet ce n'est même pas le contraire
de l'evian si on n'aime pas l'eau du
robinet du vitesse on n'aime pas l'eau
d'evian
j'ai pas là vous dit demeurer le soir du
nouvel an les autres soirs le truc c'est
pas faire la fête tout le monde pour pas
être un mouton baisse modérée pour
commencer rafah nached aux siens dans
des excès à considérer le lendemain du
nouvel an est à qu'à dormir comme ça si
on a trop bu la veille
on se lève à 6 heures du soir c'est pas
mal car on commence la fête le premier
soir que ça on est un décalage des
angoisses que le 31 au soir et puis le
premier au soir on fait la fête
vous allez à condition que de bas c'est
ce que je peux faire ch pourra gpo prévu
ça ne dérange pas le nouvel an c'est
rien pour moi
[Musique]